[Applause]
there's no bad blood between Katy Perry
and Taylor Swift anymore the two seemed
to have ended their years long feud and
guys it looks like a collab could be on
the horizon on Tuesday Katy took to
Instagram to share this pic
that's a plate of chocolate chip cookies
with the words peace at last
written on the plate in red frosting but
here's the part that has the internet
losing their damn minds the pop star
captioned the shot quote feels good
Taylor Swift I'm so excited oh but it
gets even better
Katy geotag to the location on her post
as let's be friends okay so I just want
to point out here that that phrase is 13
letters now Swifties know that's
Taylor's magic number okay my feels are
at an all-time high and get this et
learned that Taylor actually made the
cookies for Katy if you thought that was
the end of the love fest oh you are
wrong shortly after Katy shared the pic
on Instagram
Taylor replied in the comments section
with a ton of heart emojis 13 hearts to
be exact
yeah there's that number again naturally
the internet went into a full-fledged
meltdown over the exchange and now fans
want a collab one user shared this
footage of Katy Perry on American Idol
writing in all caps Katy Perry featuring
Taylor Swift we finally won Katy cats
and Swifties OMG music industry is
shaking right now
another wrote Taylor Swift featuring
Katy Perry concept and fans might just
be in luck check out what Katy told et
in March about the possibility of a
Taylor Katy track we're so excited to
get new music from you but here's the
thing Taylor Swift was just on this
carpet before you what about the rumors
that Katy Perry and Taylor Swift could
make music together I mean I'm making
music was dead I'm open open open open
some fans seem to think peace at last
could be the title of their song ad
the two peace sign stealers seemingly
frosted onto the plate and you've got 13
characters again this has to be assigned
and Taylor nation proved yet again that
they are the best detectives on the
entire planet pointing out that the
marble countertop in the pic Katie
posted is the same marble countertop
that Taylor has in her kitchen leading
many to wonder if they met up at
Swifty's house but honestly you guys
no one wrapped up by personal feelings
on the matter like this fan who shared
this meme of Taylor writing y'all if
Taylor Swift and Katy Perry post a pic
together a sister is gonna die
she's dead the post comes weeks after
fans noticed that Taylor added Katie's
new song to her playlist by me on Apple
music and Katie liked Taylor's most
recent tweet a pic of her cat Benjamin
Button their reported feud began in 2014
but in 2018 Katie sent Taylor a literal
Olive Branch as well as a note that was
addressed hey old friend from what we
could make out it read I've been doing
some reflecting on past
miscommunications and the feelings
between us I really want to clear the
air I'm deeply sorry
dot-dot-dot my source at the time told
ET that Katie gave her apology a lot of
thought before sending it and she was
willing to keep trying if Taylor didn't
accept it of course Taylor did respond
and shared this on her Instagram stories
so I just got to my dressing room and
found this actual Olive Branch this
means so much to me I am so ready for
this feud to be over and done with
of course we'll make sure that we keep
you up to date on all the details of
this budding friendship so make sure you
keep it locked right here on ET until
next time I'm Hallie Stephens bye for
now
[Music]